[Musique]
avec voulait une phrase bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse hellène aujourd'hui l'émotion
d'abord des parlementaires britanniques
auxquelles le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky aps s'est adressé
hier dans un discours en visioconférence
mais les bombardements ne nous ont pas
brisé nous ne perdrons pas peu importe
le prix nous nous battrons dans les
forêts dans les champs sur les rivages
dans les rues a lancé volodymyr zelensky
cité par des ae qui évoque une adresse
shirt chiliennes faisant écho au
discours du premier ministre winston
churchill en juin 1940 une intervention
qui a été ovationnée par les
parlementaires britanniques l'ukraine
qui ont déjà fait plus de deux millions
de personnes elle n en moins de deux
semaines de couple essentiellement
regroupés pour le moment en tout cas
dans les pays frontaliers de l'ouest de
l'ukraine la pologne la slovaquie la
hongrie et la roumanie ces deux millions
de réfugiés sont appelés à être prise en
charge tout ou tard par d'autres pays
européens en belgique le soir dit
espérer que bruxelles sera à la hauteur
de ce défi tout en relevant que
l'accueil d'une population étrangère
constitue à un moment sensible pour
toute société
susceptible de se transformer en pomme
de discorde s'il n'est pas encadrée en
france l'humanité
gouvernement annonce la création d'une
plateforme pour faciliter l'accueil des
réfugiés d'ukrainiens l'humanité donc
exprime sa solidarité et appelle ses
lectrices et lecteurs à envoyer des dons
et des mots pour la paix en partenariat
avec le secours populaire français la
solidarité l'aide et l'accueil de tous
les réfugiés qui fuient la guerre
l'oppression et la misère sont une
nécessité et un devoir d'humanité plaide
le journal des appels à l'accueil et à
la solidarité qui font grincer quelques
dents en europe et ailleurs dans le
monde en arabie saoudite pourtant peu
réputé pour l'accueil des étrangers le
quotidien officiel as 12 s'indigne des
préjugés et du deux poids deux mesures
dont les autres les européens feraient
preuve envers les réfugiés le journel et
trio passage pauline les commentaires
entendus à la télévision témoignant
selon lui du racisme désinvolte des
journalistes occidentaux dans leur
couverture de la guerre le quotidien
cite la responsable de la division
europe de l' ong human rights watch sur
le traitement inégalitaire réservé par
lieu aux réfugiés judith sunderland dit
observer un contraste frappant je la
cite entre la réponse de lieux aux
réfugiés se craignent à et celle qu'elle
a adressée qu'elles adressent aux
syriens aux avances d'irakiens et aux
érythréens entre autres face à la
catastrophe humanitaire en cours en
ukraine les états unis on en parlait
avec christophe dans sept à l'instant où
annoncé hier un embargo sur les
hydrocarbures venus de russie cette
décision est saluée par le wall street
journal qui estime que joe biden a pris
la bonne décision mais qu'il se livre à
une contradiction affolante je cite en
décrétant en même temps une transition à
toute vapeur vers l'énergie verte une
décision perçue comme un assaut contre
les hydrocarbures américains pour
lesquels le journal demande l'abrogation
de toutes les relais de toutes les
réglementations pour limiter la hausse
des prix dans leur tentative de réduire
le coût de leur embargo sur le pétrole
le gaz le pétrole et le gaz rue saint
christophe a évoqué les etats unis se
sont adressés au venezuela mais
également pays du golfe selon le
guardian ces derniers ont refusé quant à
eux d'accéder aux demandes de washington
enfin de nous recevoir que le quotidien
britannique qu'elle explique par le
refroidissement des relations entre ces
pays et les états unis sous
l'administration joe biden en france
l'embargo américain auquel se refusent
les européens est perçu comme une
déclaration de guerre économique envers
la russie une pour libération ce
durcissement du bras de fer entre
washington et moscou fait planer le
risque d'un choc économique sans
précédent depuis un demi siècle il ya là
tous les ingrédients d'une crise
d'approvisionnement comme l'europe n'en
a pas connu depuis des décennies
prévient la croix qui évoque le casse
tête des européens confrontés à la
nécessité de limiter dorénavant leur
dépendance aux hydrocarbures russes
ailleurs dans le monde la guerre en
ukraine fait aussi planer le spectre
d'une crise alimentaire le panarabe de
londres alarab fait état de l'inquiétude
des égyptiens face à une hausse des prix
qui s'est étendue à leurs besoins les
plus élémentaires hausse du prix du blé
en particulier dont la russie et
l'ukraine fournissent 80% des
importations égyptienne du d'égypte et
surtout vu d'ukraine évidemment
l'inquiétude occidentales concernant les
prix de l'énergie semble bien dérisoire
à ces pauvres américains confrontés aux
prix élevés de l'essence compatissent
des ukrainiens sous les bombes un dessin
signer mec lukowich ans ne se quittent
pas là dessus elle n a rien de tel qu'un
peu de foot n'est ce pas pauline pour se
changer un peu les idées alors les fans
de foot en tout cas en retiennent leur
souffle avant la rencontre de ce soir je
parle bien sûr du déplacement du psg sur
la pelouse du real madrid pour les
huitièmes de finale retour de la ligue
des champions l'équipe nous apprend et
je sens que ça va vous transporter de
joie 1 pauline que kilian bape ait dit
kiki et bien il va mieux et qu'il est
même tout à fait d'attaqué après sa
petite blessure à l'entraînement lundi
le journal frise déjà la crise
d'apoplexie
temps en
attendant le retour du génie titre le
journal en toute sobriété avec la police
de la guerre des étoiles espère espérons
que ça nous on ne pas plutôt à l'empiré
contre attaque transporté je suis merci
beaucoup et l'aisne